- Hi, I'm Dylan Sprouse.
I play Trevor in "After We Collided,"
which is coming soon to U.S. theaters.
And today I'm going to
be taking a BuzzFeed quiz
on which Sprouse twin I really am.
Maybe, maybe what my soul is.
I hope I get Dylan.
(upbeat music)
- First things first,
pick another set of
iconic twins to hang with.
Mary Kate and Ashley Olsen,
Tia and Tamera Mowry,
Joel and Benji Madden,
Aaron and Shawn Ashmore.
I think I would go with Tia and Tamera,
I've met them and they just seem
like a blast to hang out with.
So those are the two I would pick.
Select a Disney series DVD
to bring with you to a deserted Island.
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody,
Wizards of Waverly place, Hannah Montana,
and That's So Raven.
Hmm.
Wow, that's tough.
I think I would probably, I
know it sounds silly to say,
but I think I would
actually do The Suite Life,
only because if I was on a
deserted island it would...
It would fill me with
joy to see my friends
and family in those episodes together.
It would remind me to keep
on hanging in there in
the deserted Island.
Choose a Sprouse role,
you know, for funsies.
Julian McGrath from Big Daddy,
Nick from Banana Split,
Billy or Bobby from That '70s Show,
Trevor from After We Collided,
Ben Geller from Friends, Will
Newman from Five Feet Apart.
Hmm, who would I choose?
That's a good one.
I would do Julian McGrath from Big Daddy.
A lot of fun memories there.
I get to relive my six year
old experience in New York
for the first time.
That would be fun.
That looks like Cole there.
You can always tell
because he's got very
large two front teeth.
My teeth, since I was a rowdy little lad,
we're chipped in places
and, I was very scrappy.
That's definitely Cole there.
Look at it his angelic little smile.
Wow, what an angel.
Choose a dynamic duo to snack on.
Peanut butter and jelly, bacon and eggs,
spaghetti and meatballs,
cheese and crackers.
I'm a big PB and J guy.
It's my favorite.
That's either between that or the BLT.
So I'm going to do
peanut butter and jelly,
and I'm going to do like one of those
artisanal thick peanut butters
and a nice strawberry jelly.
And then I cut the crust off
because I'm an artist
and I'll eat that on potato bread.
Pick a Tipton regular to live with.
Mr. Moseby, London Tipton,
Maddie Fitzpatrick, Arwin Hawkhauser.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
Geez, I love the photos that
you picked for this too.
If I had to pick a regular to live with,
I'd pick London Tipton,
I mean, she's got the
run of the Tipton Hotel.
So I'd either do that
or I would pick Arwin
Hawkhauser because Arwin,
in the show, always was making
these really cool gadgets
that we would play around with.
So it's one of those two,
I picked Awrin.
Pick a hobby to take up in your twenties.
Narrative podcasting,
Polaroid photography,
brewing artisanal alcohols,
writing comic books.
Wow, I don't know.
That's tough.
I would probably say
brewing artisanal alcohols.
That just sounds like
something a wizard would do.
Finally, choose a Riverdale plot line
that sounds fake but is totally real.
(laughing)
- Oh, Cole would love this.
When Betty found out she
had the serial killer gene,
when Archie got mauled by a bear,
when Jughead delivered his,
"I'm a weirdo" speech out of the blue,
when Cheryl waterboarded
her mother with maple syrup,
oh god.
(laughing)
- When Edgar Evernever
and his organ-harvesting
cult joined the fold,
when Veronica ran an
underground speakeasy.
Well I was actually in Vancouver
when Archie got mauled by a bear,
it was really funny to be there for that.
But when Cheryl waterboarded her mother
with maple syrup is the
most extremely bizarre
thing I've ever read.
So I think I'm gonna pick that one.
I got Dylan Sprouse!
You're the older wiser, and
dare I say more dashing twin.
Ooh, stop.
You're mellow and a bit mysterious
but that just draws people
closer, closer into your orbit.
Wow, okay.
I gotta say that was a really nice
little blurb at the end there.
I think you're giving me
a little too much credit
but I'll take it, I guess on
the inside I am actually Dylan.
What a lovely quiz.
(upbeat music)